bene tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono su gta 5 ragazzi con lo
steccone nazionale elbow march io non
sono nazionale nella quale marchi e
regionale oggi ci giochiamo
l'international io sono continental
altro che bello allora io non sai cosa
dobbiamo fare questo genere
io non ho idea di cosa dobbiamo fare sei
una rampa gigante
oddio perché sapevo se starò bene
scendiamo la rampa ok melograno fare
tipo fi 25 volte per che cosa
ogni volta che scendi diventi un aereo
torni su e quando inizi sia un veicolo
diverso andrà sempre peggio e quindi per
ora scendi la rampa le domande oddio io
so ma tu sei pazzo ma come faccio è
marcita non passato io no sta andando
abbastanza bene teoricamente sai cos'è
questa è la fortuna di princi certo la
dicevano tutti anche a ronaldinho lo
dicevano ma io non lo so
eccolo l'ho fatta oddio che è successo a
so diventato la rucola e mo che faccio
adesso devi tornare all'inizio
all'antitrust negato via all'inizio
tutto su estero impossibile che hanno
fatto subito non so io per donare come
faccia allora arrivato sopra ma adesso
deve arrivare a dovetti segni allo sport
lo prendi diventi un nuovo veicolo d'oro
preso il piano però lo prenda padova
orribile un camion crudi ma al camion
orribile bello il senso sa cos'è è
diventato una star a dovere attenzione
stando bene ma se la cava è facilissimo
basta impennare un po subito e poi lo fa
esatto non ho capito avevano lavato e
fatto cioè allora ci di prendere in giro
ma non lo so siete voi che ci conoscete
meglio gt iron non ho idea fetta vera
come si vanta il ragazzo infatti che
riguarda sono primo prima ancora prima
dalla barba è cambiato è lo so che non
sono piccoli lavori comunque sta cosa
dell'aeroplano anche l'aeroplano è
diverso cosa è bello non credo nassi non
è il campo da questo è bellissimo
se ci possono stare no non puoi credo
che pur col peccato perché sarebbe stato
molto divertente ma posso anche invece
andargli addosso servizi si pero poi
anche quello posso farlo è però non lo
faccio perché non si sa mai li porca
vacca difficilissimo come farli no va
bene lo posso mai prendere il vero che
l'ho preso l'ho preso preso ha preso lo
pregio cosa sei diventato una smart e
sono caduto all'altro post ma lo smart
vi voglio vedere allora con l'aereo che
se lo merita e ma non lo trovo eccolo
non ce la faccio non rompere va via è
ormai sono passate da rai che piccola
smart la smart è più piccola dei
passaggi tra una teca e tra una tegola e
l'altra occhi occhio che sta arrivando
in picchiata fortissimo nolano togliti
ce l'ho fatta
ok sono la loro nuova ragazza bellissima
parola ce l'hai fatta con la smart ed è
bellissimo giu la spagna
anzi quando scendi di melo che che
arrivò sto ragazzo un campione ormai sei
decisamente più forti noi non sa più
dalle 6 2 6 2 6 che si scorna sono
ancora su tranquillo dimmi quando scendi
no non può essere qui per guardare dalla
branca ciao 6
ecco oggi o che no vabbè c'è il camion i
fornai qualche cambio sino ai ma non lo
so sembra quello di forte anche quando
parti
vabbè nova penso che parlando soltanto
di nuovo l'ora per colpa tua
io non lo so io riesco io con la smart e
non capisco direi buttare l'halacha
perché se togliti no non ci credo non ti
devi buttare film io tutto spostato io
che mi disse guarda ho avuto il quello
che mi meritavo col karma perché sta
rotolando giù come una patata lessa
però sto ancora in piedi ma deve
ricadere maledetto e ho capito lavora
senza forse ci riesco
no peccato è difficilissimo questo
camion garda la casa dobbiamo darci dei
ritmi perché sennò non scendiamo che
pare che ho fatto ho preso ritmo con la
smart guardano mio di lardo ballo ci
credo è sana ma non ci credo le due ore
che provo io sto fatto segreto il
capitol po è tutto lì cosa il
contraccolpo delle onde d'urto e quindi
cosa devi fare una critica a spiegartelo
però le azioni chimica bravo bravo in
tutto fatto l'ho fatto e visto il
contagio e contraccolpo delle onde
d'urto non solo spiegarlo non ti
avvicinare che è stato un casino ma
mancano solo 15 macchine
mamma mia carriera finita
se è così non ho toccato march che però
mi asti ha fatto spiaccicare guarda sono
indietro di uno e sono veramente
arrabbiata con voi come indietro di due
perché ha fatto dal primo tentativo
anche questa parlai staff si avvia non
si sta facendo loro non lo sai
quest'anno quello lo vi ho intravisto
solo ho solo intravisto sono auto
esploso è il prossimo non mi piace per
nulla
ora che il retro il letto non sto
facendo il retro nuova veri credibile no
vabbè ragazzi milioni in like fa vicino
è fatta però ce l'ho fatta sono quando
deve furgoncini stessa del suo maledetto
è andato avanti contraccolpo e ragazzi
aspettati schianti no forse no devi devi
togliere ti devi togliere raddrizzato
gara mi devi pagare a lotti di non
toccare immobile
togli timbro
mi dissocio nome ne vanno questo non
deve avere più niente da fare così al
canale certo chi è quelle marci
no sono io vabbè station o ragazzi la
prima ultimo perché stefano mi ha rotto
le balle pero vinci sanremo lei va bene
certo se vinco quella di trovarci di
trovarla che lo più veloce è morto no no
fai il bravo l'italiano fratello mio mi
dispiace tantissimo è stato bellissimo
dove sei al tempismo
mamma mia se ti vedevo guarda che da
rally fatto una cosa veramente cattiva è
impossibile il veicolo che aveva ma si
può trasformare anche per volare oddio
ma vi prego laga alla terza volta di
fila no però ce l'ho fatta subito dove
che sei step no ma perché mi era già una
scuola calcio e primo esito si sta
concentrando ce l'ha fatta ci ha fatto
ce l'ha fatta da cosenza sostanza non
sbattendo di faccia sulla rampa da due
ore ecco esiste sinistra era ultimo no
bravissimo arrivando adesso non è che ce
l'ha poi ce la puoi fare lo re ce la
puoi fare
c s.stefano già fa adesso sì che ti
garantisco che un'esperienza che non
vuoi vivere impulsi vediamo e fattiva i
pianino piani dolore pianino piano piano
contro il corpo l'indietro vai vai vai
un po più veloce è troppo ok ok un
bellissimo no vabbè non ci credo diciamo
che non sono messo male ma io ti vedo
dove sta e al traguardo
sì l'ho fatto ma dai suoi rate ultima la
prima barriera così difficile che si
riapra è quello il discorso no ragazzi è
stata l'esperienza più bella della mia
vita che ma farà gabellone conosciuto
l'esperienza delle rampe nelle facciamo
una delle settimane benissimo quindi
ragazzi che sarà rampa delle macchine
belle con stef
march è stato meravigliosa vinto march
meritatamente non si può dire niente
però mi sono successe poi di sgarbi li
ho visti e cioè non bisogna buttare giù
gli amici sta cosa qua io infatti non
hanno una volta però vabbè non fa niente
spero che vi sia piaciuto di schede
anche a ragazzi passato anche la marcia
estetico dei sapresti piacersi aiuti gta
e noi continuiamo nel prossimo episodio
un bacino ciao ciao
[Musica]